[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 138 of our
currently daily "Google
Cloud Platform" podcast.
My name is Mark Mandel.
I'm here with my colleague
as always, Melanie Warrick.
MELANIE WARRICK: Day 2.
Day 2 of Next.
MARK MANDEL: Day
2 of Next, indeed.
It's been pretty great.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, it has been.
It's been a busy day.
Lots going on here.
MARK MANDEL: Lots
and lots going on.
So we've got a
bunch of interviews
happening today with people
here on the show floor at Next.
But what exciting things have
you been particularly excited
by in the keynote today?
MELANIE WARRICK: The
rotating stage platforms.
That's what I've
been excited about.
MARK MANDEL:
Rotating containers.
Everything comes in containers.
MELANIE WARRICK: Everything
is in containers.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
MELANIE WARRICK: Some
of the announcements
are around edge computing,
and specifically
edge TPUs and Cloud
IoT Edge, which I think
is kind of exciting.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
I really like Cloud Armor.
I think that looks really great.
I wish they'd spelled Armor
with a U. But it's fine.
I'll live with it.
So that's DDoS and
application defense systems
and services with
geo-based access
control, which is really sweet.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And there's additional
information out there
about tightened security
keys, a FIDO security
key with firmware developed by
Google to verify its integrity,
which I think is kind of cool.
MARK MANDEL: I have one
of the little Titan keys
from last year.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh yeah?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One of the little ones.
MELANIE WARRICK: No,
I haven't seen that.
MARK MANDEL: Also,
there's a whole bunch
of stuff-- container registry
vulnerability scanning.
I'm particularly
excited about that.
So we have integrated
stuff for you
when you have containers
we do security scanning,
so we can see if there's
anything that should be fixed
and stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's very important.
MARK MANDEL: It is.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Mark, I think we've
got a bunch of people we're
going to chat with today.
So let's go do that.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
we're happy to have
join us Haben Girma, who is
an advocate for accessibility
in tech.
And I know, Haben, you're
here with us at Next.
You just gave a talk on
accessibility in tech
not too long ago.
Thank you for being
part of the podcast.
HABEN GIRMA: Absolutely.
It's an honor to be here.
So my name is Haben Girma.
And I am deafblind.
I have limited
vision and hearing.
I can use technology when it's
designed to be accessible.
And it's my hope to
teach more developers
how to design products and
services that are accessible.
MARK MANDEL: So we have recorded
a full interview with you,
which will be coming up soon.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: But to
tease a little of what
we talked about
previously, could you
tell us a bit about what
you talked about here
at Cloud Next?
HABEN GIRMA: The main
takeaway from the presentation
this morning is that
developers have the power
to build services that
everyone can access.
A lot of people assume that
people with disabilities
don't use computers or
don't use smartphones,
and ignore the
disability community
when building services.
Don't make those assumptions.
Design with everyone in mind,
There are 1.3 billion
people with disabilities
around the world.
We're the largest
minority group.
People who invest
in accessibility
get to tap into
this large market.
So it's more business, more
revenue in the long run
if you design with
access in mind.
So I want to encourage
everyone to stop thinking
about disability as charity.
Instead, think of it as
a business opportunity.
MELANIE WARRICK: What's
your favorite technology
that's accessible, and also just
a technology everybody's using?
HABEN GIRMA: I'm a
huge fan of the iPhone,
because it has
accessibility built
in that lots of people
with disabilities
and non-disabled people can use.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
mobile phone usage
in regards to what type of
aspects work best for you?
HABEN GIRMA: So with my
phone, I now have easy access
to communicate with people.
Before that-- before,
I couldn't text.
And without the ability to
text, if I'm traveling around
and need to talk to someone,
get environmental information,
maybe an emergency alert, I
wouldn't be able to get that.
But now because I have a
smartphone with accessibility
built in, I have access
to emergency alerts,
to fun conversations,
to restaurant reviews.
And I have so much more
freedom now with an accessible
phone than I did before
accessible phones were
available.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
are some resources
and outside organizations that
you would recommend for people
to check out if they're
interested in understanding
how to be better in designing
accessibility in tech?
HABEN GIRMA: My
website has information
about accessibility.
So you're welcome to check out
my website-- habengirma.com.
Some local organizations--
San Francisco LightHouse
for the Blind.
You can also check out
the National Federation
of the Blind--
NFE.org or by the National
Association of the Deaf.
There are lots of organizations
that can help provide
information on accessibility.
MELANIE WARRICK: What's
been your favorite thing
at Next so far?
HABEN GIRMA: I love
meeting people.
I've had the opportunity to
meet lots of cool people here.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Haben, thank you
so much for joining us
on the podcast today.
And look forward to listening
to the full episode that
will come out later in
the next few months.
HABEN GIRMA: Thanks
for having me here.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
we're excited to have
join us Paresh Kharya.
Great.
He is from NVIDIA.
And thank you for
coming to join us today.
PARESH KHARYA: Thanks
a lot for having me.
MELANIE WARRICK: So tell us
a little about who you are
and what you do over at NVIDIA.
PARESH KHARYA: Sure.
So I'm Paresh Kharya,
responsible for product
marketing for our
data center products.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
And I know you're here
today, NVIDIA's here today.
There's a big NVIDIA presence.
Can you tell us about
what that's all about?
PARESH KHARYA: Yeah, sure.
So my company, NVIDIA, invented
the GPU two decades ago
that basically revolutionized
the modern computer graphics.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
PARESH KHARYA: And also
revolutionized parallel
computing.
More recently, deep
learning powered by the GPUs
have been responsible
for advancements
in artificial intelligence.
And we are very
happy about that.
GPU computing is also
available across all
the different computing
form factors from desktops
to devices to servers to cloud
services from our partners
like Google.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You're here at Next
because you had a big
announcement yesterday.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
PARESH KHARYA: Yeah, sure.
We're very excited about that.
So we announced that our
Tesla P4 GPUs are coming
to Google Cloud Platform.
P4 is basically a small form
factor, highly specialized
for AI inference workloads GPU.
And while our GPUs--
flagship GPUs like V100--
have been available
for a while, Google
is the first cloud
platform to make
P4 available on a global scale.
And this speaks to
the tipping point
of how AI inference is becoming
really important as a workload.
Now, P4 is ideally suited
for the real time inference
workloads that require
really fast processing.
So think of services like
speech-based interfaces,
or real time live translations,
understanding of video,
and so on.
P4 can process AI
workloads that are really
complex 40 times faster than
what's possible on CPUs alone.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's fast.
Well, you probably
heard us talk about this
in the past in regards to
inference and training.
But Paresh, do you mind
explaining just briefly
what is inference?
PARESH KHARYA: Yeah.
That's a great question.
So training a neural network
is when you're basically
pumping in a lot of data to
help a neural network learn
by taking a look at the
data and the labels that
are associated with data.
So that's the training step.
It's computationally
very complex.
Inference is when you're putting
that trained neural network
to work.
So it looks at new data,
and it makes predictions.
So for example, if it's
about recognizing speech,
it's taking in a
new spoken sentence.
And it's able to recognize it.
So that's the AI inference.
MARK MANDEL: That's
really great.
We should also note that
we have episode 119 where
we talk to Bryan Catanzaro
from NVIDIA, talking
about deep learning as well.
So people want to hear more
about that kind of thing
as well.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Agreed, definitely.
Well, what do you enjoy--
what have you enjoyed or seen
so far that you've been
excited about outside
of the announcement?
PARESH KHARYA: Yeah, absolutely.
So one of the really
exciting things
for me personally is
Google's pioneering use
of artificial intelligence in
adding magic to your services,
like--
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, magic.
PARESH KHARYA: Exactly.
Whether it's the G
Suite or optimizing
the performance of your data
centers-- massive data centers.
And Google is not just keeping
its technology to itself.
It's basically making it
available to everyone,
every industry, and enabling
them to be transformed by AI.
Google and NVIDIA, we
have a strong partnership.
And we both understand the
need for accelerated computing
to help advance AI.
And Google continues to
invest in DPUs, for example.
But at the same time, Google
is also relying on GPUs
to power its own internal
AI, as well as they are
making it available as a cloud
service on the Google Cloud
Platform.
So every deep learning framework
and the diversity of modern AI
can be supported.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Well, we appreciate you
coming by to chat with us
on the podcast.
Anything else you wanted to
mention before we let you go?
PARESH KHARYA: Yeah.
It's a really exciting time.
We are witnessing
a new revolution
in terms of artificial
intelligence
and what it can do to
revolutionize the workflows
and simplify our lives, as well
as revolutionize industries.
And we're just at
the tipping point
right now where
people are realizing
all of this is possible.
We're very happy
to work with Google
to make our GPU
computing technology
available through the
Google Cloud Platform
to help companies and
industries transform themselves.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, thank you so much
for coming to join us here
on the Next Showroom floor.
PARESH KHARYA: You're welcome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
PARESH KHARYA: I appreciate it.
MELANIE WARRICK: So joining
us are Amruta Gulanikar.
And we have Simon Zeltser.
And we're going to talk a
little bit about what's being
presented in regards to Windows
SQL Server and .NET Workloads
on GCP.
So thanks for joining us.
SIMON ZELTSER:
Thanks for having us.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Thank you.
Glad to be here.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Do you want to tell us a
little about who you are
and what you do here at Google?
SIMON ZELTSER: Sure.
So I'm Simon Zeltser.
I'm developer programs
engineer focusing on workloads
of Windows and .NET
running on GCP.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Hi.
I'm Amruta.
I'm a product manager on
Google Compute Engine.
And I own making sure that
Windows and SQL server
workloads work well
on the platform.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, what are you all excited
about in regards to Next?
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Lots of stuff.
SIMON ZELTSER: There are so
many things to be excited about.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah?
What are a couple in particular
around the whole Windows SQL
Server and .NET workloads?
AMRUTA GULANIKAR:
So first is, we're
really excited about
the fact that we
have amazing amount
of migration tootling
support available for our
lift and shift workloads.
There are some really cool demos
about Velostrata, a company
that we acquired recently.
And that also has a lot of
support for Windows workloads,
especially.
We're also really, really
excited about all the support
that we have for
.NET containers,
which are running
on GKE and GAE.
And there's a lot of buzz
around GKE and a lot of support
for running workloads in a
modernized fashion on Google
Cloud.
So we are excited to share.
Simon's going to be
demoing some stuff
to show you how you can take
your legacy applications
into the new world.
So we are really excited to
show some of those capabilities.
MARK MANDEL: What are
you demoing, Simon?
SIMON ZELTSER: I'm going
to demo two things.
First is how we can lift and
shift legacy .NET application
into Google Cloud as is.
And then the second demo is
going to be about modernization
of that application,
splitting the monolith
into microservices, and then
running it in .NET containers,
some Linux on GKE.
And also we have a preview
of Stackdriver Debugger,
which allows us to do snapshot
debugging of our .NET workloads
in production, which
is really, really cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: That is great.
So any places that people
can go look for in regards
to additional resources for
Windows SQL Server and .NET
workloads?
AMRUTA GULANIKAR:
Yeah, absolutely.
So we have two sessions that
are going to happen on day one.
There is session
number 1 at 3:15.
It is around Active Directory.
And we have a customer, Capital
One, who's going to come
and showcase how they brought
their workloads to GCP.
We also have a followup
session at 4:35
where Simon's going to do the
demo that he just talked about.
And we're going to talk about
all the platform features that
you have on support for Windows
SQL Server and .NET workloads.
We also have a booth where we're
going to have a .NET experts
to come and talk to us.
And we have a ton of
information on our website.
So go to
cloud.google.com/windows,
cloud.google.com/sql-server,
.NET, and so on.
So forth.
And we have a page with a lot of
resources and links out there.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Is there anything
else we've missed
that you want to make sure
that people want to know about?
AMRUTA GULANIKAR:
Well, come talk to us.
We'll be hanging out.
And we're excited about all
the new stuff to show you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, thank you
both for joining.
SIMON ZELTSER:
Thanks for having us.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Thank
you for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
So we have two
completed students
from Holberton School--
Henry Hsu and Isaac
Wong joining us today.
Henry, how are you doing?
HENRY HSU: Great.
Doing great.
Thanks for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Isaac, how you doing?
ISAAC WONG: Doing wonderful.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
So why don't you tell us a
little bit about Holberton
School and your
experience there?
HENRY HSU: Holberton School is
a two-year college alternative
training software engineers.
It's pretty much project-based.
There's no instructors.
And it's just pure
learning and project-based
to kind of try to emulate a more
realistic approach to learning,
as opposed to just giving you
assignments that you do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
ISAAC WONG: Yeah.
It also has a deferred
tuition model.
So we don't pay anything
until we get jobs.
Once we get jobs
and they pay us,
we pay the school
back for training us.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: What are some
of the things you're studying?
HENRY HSU: So we start off
primarily by doing low level
programming, learning
old school C.
And then after that, we do
that for about three months.
And then we progress on
to higher level languages,
like Python and JavaScript.
And then we also do some
DevOps training also
to learn Linux and
bash shell scripting.
And then make some
full stack web apps.
So that's the broad
overview condensed.
ISAAC WONG: Yeah.
And so I'm actually
in class right now.
And yesterday I was
working on a MySQL project
to make a backend
for an Airbnb clone.
And so it's ramping
towards doing
like DevOps as [INAUDIBLE]
kind of work there.
So this is a very interesting
conference for us at the time.
MARK MANDEL: So speaking,
we are here at Cloud Next.
What have you seen?
What has been particularly
exciting to both of you?
HENRY HSU: I come from a
health care background.
So when I saw the speech that
they were giving yesterday
about how they're leveraging
cloud technology to kind
of improve patient treatment,
that was very interesting
to me, especially
since I'm kind of
trying to see if I can still
translate some of my domain
knowledge in the health care
sector into technology work.
So hearing about that, that
was very interesting to me.
On a less serious note,
I'm also kind of a gamer.
So when I went up
there and I saw
what they were doing with
the slow-dancing robot,
and then they also
showcasing some of the games
that's made in Unity, which
apparently transitioned
from AWS2 to cloud.
So that was really awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark knows
a little bit about that.
MARK MANDEL: A little.
A little smidge.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
there's an activity
later today that you're
specifically supporting.
You want to talk about
that for a second?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So I'm doing--
there's actually going
to be a gaming meetup/birds of
a feather conversation happening
at 4:00 PM on Moscone 2.
It'll be this afternoon.
So if you're listening
to the podcast,
unfortunately, this
is no use to you.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You've missed it.
But you should talk to
the people who went.
Anyways.
So I know when we were
starting out the podcast,
you both were sharing
some interesting knowledge
I think would be very useful for
others who go to conferences.
What are some best
practices on gathering swag?
ISAAC WONG: OK.
So if you're a shameless
poor student like Henry
and I, what you do when
you go to a conference,
you find a booth
that has swag bags.
You know those fancy bags?
And then you use that bag
to go around to other booths
to get like, you know,
candy, chocolate pens, robust
trinkets that you can show
around from the conference.
Yeah.
And most people are very
willing to give us candy.
Like, I think Mark and
Melanie are offering
us full bowls of candy here.
As long as you ask for
it, you're fine taking it.
You just go over there and
pouring the whole candy
into your bag.
Yeah.
It's not nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's
a different situation.
ISAAC WONG: Ask.
Ask.
MARK MANDEL: Isaac,
what cool stuff have
you found particularly great?
ISAAC WONG: Yeah.
So I might be
naive, but I thought
it was really interesting when
they announced the GKE On-Prem
server.
I thought that was really cool.
I'm not too involved in that
sort of [INAUDIBLE] kind
of work here, but that seemed
like a very nice innovation
there.
And I'm really interested
to see how that develops.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And you're right.
It is a very cool innovation.
ISAAC WONG: And
so me personally,
[INAUDIBLE] Henry's from
the health care background.
I'm actually from an
agricultural background.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
ISAAC WONG: And so I think--
I'm not sure if it's
today or tomorrow,
but I'm interested in
the session tomorrow
by a company that's trying to
incorporate machine learning
in the field of agriculture
to see how that advances that.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Have you both been
going to sessions
while you're here as well?
HENRY HSU: I plan to
go to more of it today.
After this I'm going
to make the rounds.
MARK MANDEL: What sessions
are you planning on going to?
HENRY HSU: Well, I want to try
to hit some of more of the--
again, the gaming and
entertainment ones.
MARK MANDEL: I'm OK with that!
That's my jam.
That's my thing.
So that's great.
HENRY HSU: OK.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Was this planted?
MARK MANDEL: No, it wasn't.
It wasn't.
Any particular gaming
sessions you want to go to?
HENRY HSU: I saw that
they have the booth--
the dancing robot one.
I didn't actually get
to see it in session.
Like, I was kind of waiting.
But then I saw they were
showing the dotless showcase.
And then so like I
got to talk to Trey,
and he was explaining to me.
And I learned a lot
about how containers
actually in virtual
machines being
used to run the matchmaking
servers and stuff like that
in the background.
So it was really interesting.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wait.
There's a dancing robot?
How did I not know about this?
Why am I not there right now?
MARK MANDEL: They have a really
amazing exhibit up there where
they've got an animator here.
And I think the other
animator is in LA.
ISAAC WONG: Oh wow.
MARK MANDEL: And they're
doing like live animation
stuff on the show floor.
On the entertainment side.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's really cool.
MARK MANDEL: It's really cool.
ISAAC WONG: I need to
go to a booth with you.
I mean, I've been
wanting to go to it,
but I was too afraid
to go to that.
So [INAUDIBLE]
HENRY HSU: Yeah, let's do it.
ISAAC WONG: I'm with you.
I went to a TensorFlow
session earlier today.
It sounds like I'm really
interested in machine learning.
I just don't know
anything about it,
so I'm here to learn about it.
So that was real
interesting for me
MELANIE WARRICK: Good
reason to be here.
ISAAC WONG: Yeah.
I mean, I was
intimidated because,
like, going through
the whole session list,
there's a whole bunch of things
which I don't know about.
But it's nice that they have
introductory sessions like that
for people like me to go to.
I went to the hands-on lab too.
Again, another good
introductory session
too for people who don't know
any about the Google products,
and it's like machine learning,
TensorFlow, things like that.
So that was cool.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK: Everybody
has to start somewhere.
So that's great that
you're doing that.
ISAAC WONG: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, thanks guys.
We really appreciate you
coming in to share with us
your experiences about Next.
HENRY HSU: Thank you.
ISAAC WONG: Thank
you for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks,
everybody for joining us again
today on day two of Next.
So Mark, I guess we got
one more day left, huh?
MARK MANDEL: One more day left.
But I think it's going to be
a really good day tomorrow.
MELANIE WARRICK: It'll be
the developer day tomorrow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So expect cool things to happen.
MELANIE WARRICK: And if you're
here, come by and say hi.
We're on Moscone West
on the first floor.
And we have lots of chocolate.
We have podcast-branded
chocolates.
You should come grab some.
MARK MANDEL: We do.
Absolutely.
You definitely should.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Have a good one.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
And have a great Next.
[MUSIC PLAYING]